23 bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france à
leur première question ces négociations
semblent engagés mais on est encore loin
de trouver un accord pensez vous qu'il
sera possible d'en trouver un rapidement
où les divergences sont encore trop
nombreuses à votre avis les divergences
sont encore nombreuses parce que là on
en est au stade où on discute des
conditions pour discuter
c'est là où on en est donc on n'est pas
encore si j'ose dire dans le fond des
dossiers et de ne fonder dossier c'est
globalement la question sociale prise au
sens large du terme en colombie comment
faire pour que ce pays sorte des
inégalités abyssales dans lesquelles il
est plongé de la pauvreté qui s'est
accélérée sous l'effet du coc vie de 19
comment mettre en place des réformes qui
sont peut-être nécessaire comme celle de
la fiscalité un moment donné où les
étals être américain dans les caisses
vides à près d'un an de combat contre le
coc vite tout ça est sur la table
comment faire pour ces réformes soient
justes sur tout et que ce pays puisse
réellement aussi atteindre la paix qui
n'existe pas en colombie malgré
formellement la signature des accords de
2016 avec les farc
c'est tout ça qui est qui veut douadi
vidéo qu'on aurait pas là on est encore
en train de discuter des conditions qui
vont permettre de négocier effectivement
il est peut-être un petit peu tôt
aujourd'hui même si on voit des signaux
qui sont quand même intéressant et
plutôt rassurant mais on en est encore
aussi avec la situation où le comité à
celle de grève aujourd'hui même appel au
moment où on se parle à de nouvelles
mobilisations dans tout le pays est
également programmé une prochaine
journée le 9 juin
donc on est dans un rapport de forces au
strip au sens strict du terme entre ce
comité de mobilisation et le
gouvernement alors des négociations et
en même temps on le voit il ya des
affrontements assez violent dans la rue
l'armée d'ailleurs est déployée
sur place on est clairement sur un
gouvernement à deux vitesses quel est le
message envoyé à la population le
gouvernement depuis le départ joue une
partition assez classique qu'est celle
d'un côté de la deûle à delà de chercher
à le montrer qu'il est prêt à discuter
d'ouvrir un dialogue
et puis de l'autre un gouvernement qui a
une stratégie de répression très forte
de la main dure comme on dit en colombie
et c'est donc là dessus que le
gouvernement dit van dyck et a choisi sa
stratégie il a choisi d'incarner l'ordre
face à ce qu'il a essayé de ne pointer
comme étant un désordre chaotique avec
organisée en sous main par soit des
terroristes des délinquants y compris le
gouvernement vénézuélien selon lui est à
la manoeuvre pour pour emmener ces
mobilisations qui a eu ce discours qui a
enfermé finalement il va doubler son
gouvernement très rapidement dans une
polarisation ce qui était le choix
stratégiques mais aujourd'hui le
gouvernement face à la durée des
mobilisations ça fait plus d'un mois
maintenant et qu'elle lui aurait tendu
dans tout le pays
et puis aussi au fait que lié au fait
que la communauté internationale entre
guillemets à commencer par le principal
allié de bogota j'entends washington et
quand même quelques peurs gêné aux
entournures à un moment où les états
unis essaient de montrer qu'ils veulent
restaurer leur leadership par bah disons
le respect des droits de l'homme des
droits humains la démocratie
manque de chance pour washington le
principal allié du puits dans la région
et bien en train de démontrer et de
montrer ma dépression assez terrible
face à des mobilisations populaires et
donc tout ça aujourd'hui se transforme
en une forme de pression amicale sur les
épaules du moment colombien qui
l'obligent il compris avec les propos de
la commissaire aux droits humains des
nations unies michelle bachelet a
cherché à peut-être ouvrir des espaces
pour des compromis et faire redescendre
la pression ce qui n'était pas forcément
son choix il ya quelques semaines nous
amenant là où on est aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs
alors les colombiens eux on a
l'impression qu'ils vivent assez mal
cette période ils sont polarisées divisé
puisqu'on l'a vu dans le sud ouest par
exemple du pays les barrages routiers
des manifestants provoque des pénuries
pour une partie de la population il ya
des manifestations des contre
manifestations
est-ce que voilà là aussi cette
confrontation pour engendrer plus de
violence parmi la population civile
à partir du moment où des mouvements
sociaux ne sont pas pris en compte
où ils sont en quelque sorte de rejeter
dans leur gîte imité par par l'état das
et les risques qui est pris et quand ça
dure et bien au bout d'un moment vous
avez des phénomènes assez classique au
conte connaît c'est que d'un côté à des
formes de radicalisation au sein des
mouvements
c'est ce qu'on voit dans le mouvement
aujourd'hui avec notamment l'implication
de la jeunesse colombienne qui
considèrent ne plus rien avoir à perdre
vu sa situation et ses conditions et qui
est à bord d'un petit peu finalement le
cadre du comité de coordination de ces
mobilisations déborde un petit peu le
cadre des structures syndicales des
structures qui participent à ce
mouvement en étant plus radicalisés en
narrant en assumant sorte d'insurrection
de la jeunesse face à la répression et
aux forces de répression de l'état et ça
c'est toujours des engrenages qui sont
mauvais mauvais parce que eh bien
lorsque la violence des poils
instrumentaliser en général par le
pouvoir pour décrédibiliser le mouvement
et puis au bout d'un moment il est vrai
que la population dans son ensemble se
fatigue aussi de situations qui crèvent
de bouleversement dans la vie
quotidienne des pénuries des problèmes
etc
et c'est tout ça qui finalement engendré
nourrit une forme de violence qui
s'installe et qui va déborde un petit
peu tout ça est le problème c'est que
lorsque le gouvernement dont c'est le
rôle n'est pas en mesure de solutionner
finalement les causes et les questions
qui étaient posées par ce mouvement
eh bien il entretient lui-même ce climat
qui peut effectivement à la fin être
hors de contrôle est posé des problèmes
ah c'est insoluble et donc c'est pour ça
que le gouvernement aujourd'hui je crois
aussi le comité de coordination voit
qu'on approche de cette zone rouge qui
peut devenir incandescent tu es assez
incontrôlable donc peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui ça va permettre de créer
les conditions d'un dialogue qui restera
fragile encore une fois comme je le
début de l'entretien
parce qu'à un moment on se parle on n'a
pas encore discuté des questions de fond
qui est à l'origine des revendications
qui mobilisait ses millions de personnes
en colombie
très bien merci beaucoup en tout cas
christophe à 23 d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de recherche à l'iris et
spécialiste d'amérique latine